l'attends avec impatience j'ai l'honneur
d'accueillir une véritable légende du
journalisme sportif c'est patrick Montel
qui sera avec nous dans quelques dans
dans dans quelques secondes pour ceux
qui ne le connaissent pas après 36 ans
d'activité c'est une personnalité
emblématique de france télé et sa voix
qui a accompagné les plus grands
exploits du sport et notamment de
l'athlétisme pendant plusieurs décennies
avant de prendre sa retraite en 2020 et
cette voix manque à beaucoup de monde
apparemment puisqueune pétition vient
d'être lancée a déjà recueilli des
dizaines de milliers de signatures ils
veulent Patrick pour les Jos de Paris il
a commenté les courses les plus
mythiques de l'histoire et euh patrick
Montel et ben il a été mis euh vous
allez voir de quelle manière il a été
sorti de France Télévision et pour
quelle raison c'est un truc de fou vous
allez voir ça pourquoi il a été sorti
euh vous après vous allez me dire que
c'est pas un prétexte vous allez voir
cette histoire est encore une histoire
folle tous les soirs à 20h55 on vous
raconte une histoire et ben c ce soir
c'est l'histoire de patrick Montel que
vous connaissez tous il va nous la
raconter dans un instant et je peux vous
dire que vous allez halluciner de ce qui
s'est passé et c'est vrai que patrick
Montel nous manque à la télévision on va
voir tiens la course mythique du monde
du Chen Bolt au 100 m en 2009 c'était
lui qui commentait
écoutez le
prier qui passe ça y parti L'Express
L'Express le TG est
parti58ord
duonde recule les limites ici à
Berlin Pat avec
nous merci Patrick d'être là franchement
je suis très content de te voir Patrick
je te tue toi ouais on se connaitt un
peu ah tu sais que je t'aime énormément
et j'ai qu'un objectif maintenant et tu
le connais je te le dirai tout à l'heure
plus de 30 ans à France Télévision à
commenté tous les sports tout le monde
connaît Patrick he je te jure on peut
pas on peut pas écouter une compétition
d'athlétisme sans avoir ta voix qui
arrive je te jure que c'est un truc de
fou c'est je sais que tu es ému ouais je
suis toujours un peu un peu ému par
rapport à ça parce que c'est c'est ce
privilège inoui d'avoir accompagné les
sportifs de haut niveau et d'avoir posé
ma voix sur la musique qu'ils étaient en
train de de créer et c'est ce que Marie
Jo Perrec m'avait dit elle m'avait dit
moi j'écrivais la musique et toi tu
écrivais les paroles et c'est une
formule qui qui m'émeut beaucoup is
alors c'était une passion to c'est une
passion il faut pas il faut pas utiliser
toi c'est vrai que toi tu es quand je
sais quand tu vois une compétition tu
t'en meurs exactement et j'aimerais bien
mourir au micro tu vois je pense
toujours à Thierry Rolland qui a presque
réussi ce ce challenge et je me dis si
ça pouvait m'arriver à moi je serais le
le plus heureux des hommes parce que
j'ai vécu des trucs exceptionnels et le
mot retraite si tu veux c'est un truc
qui me qui me fait gerber vraiment on va
en parler dans un instant c'est une
passion depuis ton plus jeune âge ça te
oui depuis l'âge de 3 ans il paraît
c'est mes parents qui m'ont raconai ça
que je fermais le poste et que je
commentais à la place des des
commentateurs alors j'avais un peu moins
de vocabulaire à l'époque mais ça me
permettait d'être moins seul en fait
ouais ouais Comé combien de de jeux
olympiques j'en suis à 12 et j'aimerais
bien le 13e ça serait bien 13 ans bah 13
et en plus dans mon jardin tu vois ça
serait cool quoi France en plus ça
serait ça serait énorme euh c'est quoi
ta ta plus belle rencontre c'est quoi ma
plus belle rencontre c'est marieo c'est
la
c'est la femme de ma vie là je suis
avecan qui est pas mal aussi mais je
peux dire que c'est la femme de ma vie
que que j'ai été profondément amoureux
de Marie- José Perrec que j'ai d'une
manière totalement platonique je précise
et j'ai j'ai épousé comment ve pas
d'histoire ici non il y aura pas
d'histoire avec Mar ça c'est sûr j'ai
épousé sa trajectoire et voilà donc mais
après j'ai eu plein plein de de privilèg
de rencontrre exceptionnel tuas arrêté
en
2019 oui j'ai arrêté euh oui j'ai arrêté
en 2019 on t'a arrêté en 2019 on va
revenir là-dessus et et depuis 3 ans tu
penses qu' une chose c'est revenir pour
ses j absolument j'ai créé un média pour
pas prendre la place de quelqu'un parce
que je ne veux surtout pas prendre la
place de quelqu'un j'ai créé quelque
chose qui n'existait pas j'ai donné la
parole à Monsieur Madame tout le monde
qui fait du sport de longue haline à qui
on ne donnait jamais la parole et
aujourd'hui on est 270000 sur Radio
Montel à suivre ces interviews et donc
ce média-là pour moi a sa place aux Jeux
Olympiques alors
euh tu as été poussé vers la sortie en
2019 par la direction de France
Télévision après euh j' j'aime pas dire
ça moi ils ont mis des propos polémiques
sur le dopage je suis pas d'accord avec
ça euh c'est pas des propos polémiques
tu as juste dit des choses euh que
d'autres champions ont déjà dit hein que
tout le monde conna d' tout le monde
connaît tu as euh eu des propos sur le
dopage ouais je les ai toujours j'ai
toujours cette phrase que je je dis je
répète je signe et je persiste ou je
persiste et je signe le dopage est
consubstantiel du sport hyper
professionnalisé donc ce que tu veux
dire c'est que tout non ce que veux dire
c'est qu'il y a une ce sont des jeunes
gens et des jeunes femmes qui veulent
performer qui veulent avoir des
médailles certains certains pas tous
heureusement certains cèdent à cette
tentation et le tout l'environnement
qu'ils ont autour ne ne ne les incite
pas à faire le contraire donc
effectivement il y a une tentation du
dopage depuis des millénaires et cette
tentation elle existe de plus en plus
dans le sport hyper professionnalisé
mais j'ai pas dit surtout pas et c'est
ce qu'on m'a reproché que tous les les
champions se dopaient évidemment
évidemment alors tu avais dit tuavais
pas dit il n'y a pas de record du monde
sans dopage non non ça j'ai jamais dit
cette phras très bien alors il y a Kevin
meer le vicechampion olympique de
Décathlon qui avait publié de nombreux
tweetil fau sur cette affaire le dopage
est un raccourci pour les flars qui
n'ont aucune je vous inviterai bien à
passer avec moi les 6 derniers mois de
ma préparation avant DOA mais ce serait
un rude sacrifice de ma part ces propos
sortant de la bouche d'un commentateur
sportif spécialisé dans l'athlétisme
faire du dopage une généralité chez les
athlètes de haut niveau autant
j'arrivais à supporter voilà exactement
exactement malgré ces nombreux défauts
mais là çaen est trop parce que la
prolong c'est votre nom sur ouais
c'était parce que la prolongation je
veux toujours prolonger le plaisir et
vous vousons voulez à Kevin meilleor pas
du tout pas du tout parce que d'abord on
s'est expliqué et il est revenu non pas
sur ses prop mais il est revenu en me en
faisant la la paix avec moi mais j'étais
jamais en guerre avec lui pe com lui il
a été blessé parce que c'est vrai que lu
beaucoup il a mal al il a il a il a
effectivement pensé je pense que des des
des langues charitables lui ont glissé à
l'oreille que j'avais dit que tous les
champions se dopaient évidemment je l'ai
jamais dit et je profite d'être là ce
soir pour dire que je suis persuadé que
Kevin Mayer ne se dope pas et je serai
son supporter numéro 1 pour les Jeux
Olympique nous aussi si toutefois je
peux y aller alors aussi euh qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé
à France Télévision parce que voilà donc
vous sortez ça qu'est-ce qui se passe
derrière parce que vous avez passé
combien d'années à France Télé plus dein
33 ans 33 ans 33 ans Fance télévision
ouais comment se passe votre éviction
parce qu'on c'est ce qu'on a envie tous
de savoir donc vous vous faites cette
sortie c'est c'est cette sortie qui qui
cette sortie je l'ai fait par rapport à
une athlète moi j'aime les athlètes
alors racontez-nous l'histoire je te
raconte l'histoire j'aime les gens
j'aime les athlètes j'aimais j'aime
toujours les athlètes et il se trouve
qu'il y a une athlète qui s'appelle
Clémence Calvin qui a été encensé parce
qu'elle a remporté une belle médaille au
championnat d'Europe et qui dans
quelques temps après a été convaincu de
dopage et moi j'ai juste voulu prendre
sa défense en disant elle va payer elle
elle a tricher elle va payer c'est
normal mais ne tirez pas sur l'ambulance
rappelez-vous ce que vous disiez sur
elle parce qu'aujourd'hui et c'est ça
aussi qui m'a valu des problèmes j'ai
dit le problème c'est pas de savoir si
vous êtes dopé ou si vous êtes pas dopé
le problème est savoir si vous faites
choper ou pas choper et ça c'est fort
ouis ouais ouais et donc et donc
derrière et donc derrière bah Kevin
Mayer et d'autres ont réagit d'une
manière très violente j'ai été convoqué
à France Télé par qui tu as été convoqué
bah j'ai été convoqué par la Direction
des Sports j'ai été convoqué par la
Direction des Sports qui m'ont dans un
premier temps mis entre guillemets à
l'abri qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'ils te
disent ils disent quoi tuarrives dans le
bureau ils disent quoi c'est ça bah ils
me disent ils me disent que j'ai j'ai
j'ai dérapé ce qui est vrai mais c'était
pas la PR dis quoi ils te disent
pourquoi tu as dit cette connerie non
parce que c'est pas c'est pas une
connerie
après la connerie c'est le c'est le la
vague des sur les réseaux c'est c'est
que ça a pris une ampleur incroyable il
y a eu une capillarité complètement dém
et et voilà après c'est vrai que je
devais commenter dans la foulée le
Marathon de Paris et que c'était
peut-être pas la meilleure chose à faire
donc il te disent quoi la direction des
sports il te dis pour l'instant la
direction des sports de France
Télévision te dit quoi la suite de cette
sortie bah elle me dit que on va mettre
à l'abri un moment et qu'on va me me
permettre de de de laisser calmer le le
truc parce qu'on sait très bien comment
ça se passe sur les réseaux ça là ils te
disent quoi tu vas re mis à l'abri
combien de temps bah ils me disent pas
mais je veux dire il il y a le Barathon
de Paris derrière et et et donc je ne
commande pas le Marathon de Paris et et
et voilà donc après après il y a un
autre problème qui est important et
c'est un problème qui dépasse le service
des sports de France Télévision et
France Télévision c'est le problème de
l'âge lorsque l'on a atteint un certain
âge on est bon à mettre à la poubelle en
France pense que c'était alors alors moi
je te dis ça oui parce que je le pense
sincèrement je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a
un vrai problème avec l'âge c'est qu'on
juge les gens non pas sur leurs compéten
non pas sur ce qu'ils peuvent apporter à
une entreprise mais on les juge aussi
sur sur leur état civil et ça c'est
juste insupportable parce que moi je
vais vous dire un truc j'ai 29 ans vous
me croyez pas et ben vous avez tort j'ai
29 ans j'ai jamais vieilli depuis l'âge
de 20 29 ans et aujourd'hui je je
réclame qu'on me foute la paix avec mon
âge et qu'on me regarde avec les yeux
d'un mec de 29 ans parce que j'ai 29 ans
vous avez 29 ans non j'ai 70 piges passé
mais jeis vous donner 29 ans désolé j'ai
29 ans Cyril je voilà alors Michel
Drucker est toujours là Michel Drucker
est toujours là Nelson mon fort aussi et
je m'en réjouis je m'en réjouis juste
Patrick parce que on raconte des
histoires tous les soirs et c'est vrai
qu'on va on va voir ton histoire donc là
le patron des sport te dit on va te
mettre à l'abri quelqu temps qu'est-ce
qui se passe derrière bah il se passe
que je suis à l'abri euh et là çave quoi
et donc fini non mais bon j'en prends
plein la tête sur les réseaux ça prend
des proportions absolument euh délirante
euh je peux plus regarder les réseaux le
matin je suis très mal et cetera donc
j'ai besoin effectivement d'être protégé
je suis protégé je suis à l'abri et
derrière ça et ben derrière ça il y a
mon âge qui se profile donc euh donc
voilà comment ça se passe il vous app B
ça se passe que euh passe un mois 2 mois
3 mois MAM tu dis je peux revenir oui
c'est ça je dis je peux revenir et on me
dit ça serait peut-être ça serait
peut-être le moment de de mettre le
clignotant ouais et donc qui te le dit
ça bah toujours pareil la direction des
sports moi je je n'ai j'ai pas à faire
avec la la la présidence ou non j'ai pas
à faire avec la présidenceentiment vous
êtes lencié avec un courrier officiel
reçu dans un bureau après 33 ans comment
il vous vire ça savoir les mots
qu'est-ce qu'il vous disent il vous mett
dans un bureau
assietoi non ça se passe pas comme ça et
après il y a une négociation qui se
passe et et on se quitte on se quitte
j'allais dire bons amis oui on se quitte
dans dans des termes corrects euh à
partir du moment je sais pas si vous
avez été amoureux dans votre vie je vous
le souhaite le gars côté oui qui toi tu
as été amoureux bon et et je souvent bon
d'accord les de jours d'accord donc tu
as pas été amoureux donc un vrai amour
avec une vraie rupture c'est très
douloureux mais quand tu as vécu quand
tu as aimé quelqu'un passionnément comme
j'ai aimé France Télévision
passionnément parce qu' elle m'a donné
tellement de choses j'ai pas envie de me
fâcher avec France Télé donc
effectivement à parttir du moment où tu
sens cy que tu es plus véritablement
dans les plans et ben tu négocies un
départ je veux dire bon voilà je veux
dire bon c'est c'est pas de guêé de cœur
mais je vais pas me fâcher avec la femme
que j'ai aimé perdument c'est pas
possible donc tu leur dis quoi
aujourd'hui non tu leuras dit quoi quand
je leurais dit j'ai essayé de me battre
pour rester maisas dit quoi tu leas dit
non je suis encore capable d'être
làvidment que je suis capable d'être là
je suis encore là mais je veux dire je
leur ai dit je leur ai dit eux ils ont
eu des arguments et à par tu sens que
que tu es plus c'était quoi les
arguments mais les arguments c'est qu'il
vaut mieux que tu passes la main parce
que ceci parce que cela et puis voilà
toi tu répondais quoi non et ben je
répondais non au début et puis à la fin
je disais bon bah écoutez ok si tu veux
plus de moi tu veux plus de moi je dire
bon mais je me suis pas si tu veux il y
a pas eu de il y a pas eu de bagarre il
y a pas eu de d'insulte il y a pas eu de
drame il y a juste eu une rupture
amoureuse que j'ai eu du mal à digérer
c'est vrai mais aujourd'hui j'ai fait
j'ai fait la paix avec tout ça je veux
dire aujourd'hui et je vais même te dire
mieux cyil aujourd'hui je je peux
écouter je peux regarder les l'atelé à
la télé commenté par mes confrères et je
vais vous dire un truc je les trouve
excellent donc je vais pas qu'est-ce que
tu veux que je te dise je les trouve bon
donc je vais pas dire le contraire mais
aujourd'hui je sais que c'est ça a été
pour toi ça a été une
déflagrationflagtion je sais je le
connais un peu je sais que tu je sais
que tous les jours tu te réveilles en
pensant ça je sais que tu nas pas dormi
des nuits entières c'est vrai c'est vrai
mais mais oui mais comme comme un
traumatismec oui ça a été un traumatisme
mais c'est le traumatisme d'un mec qui a
été qui a vécu une vie de rêve donc le
jour où ça s'arrête bah effectivement tu
tombes de ton pied d'estal mais je vais
pas faire pleurer la foule de gens qui
n'ont jamais connu ce que moi j'ai connu
donc voilà non mais tu t'y attendais
Patrick ou pas bah tu t'y attends
toujours sauf que tu veux jamais y
penser tu penses jamais que tu vas être
bon pour pour
euh pour le la pour pour partir jamais
tu penses à ça moi je te dis mon trip
depuis que je suis gamin c'est de mourir
au micro donc effectivement tu penses
pas mais il y a un moment tu es bah tu
es devant le mur et puis voilà comment
ça se passe quand tu sors du bureau de
France Télévision et que tu sais que
c'est fini pour toi et ben je pleure
vraiment tu pleures bah évidemment mais
je pleure pour pas grand-chose moi mais
mais là c'est là je pleurais oui bien
sûr que je pleure mais je pleure parce
que c'est c'est ma c'est oui c'est ma
passion qui s'effondre après j'ai après
il m'a fallu du temps pour imaginer que
je pouvais vivre sans France Télévision
et aujourd'hui je vis heureux sans
France téléion combien de temps à te
reconstruire 1 an et demi 1 an et demi h
tu pleurais souvent ouais tout le temps
ouais ouais tout le temps ouais enfin je
ouais je je pleurais très souvent et
surtout j'avais j'avais du mal à
imaginer euh vivre sans ça quoi c'est
c'était une drogue quoi donc tu faisais
quoi de tes journées tu tu tu bah je
foutais pas grand-chose et et
heureusement je vais te dire un truc
j'ai été sauvé par une dame à qui je
dois rendre hommage parce que beaucoup
de gens la tailleent sans arrêt moi je
l'adore c'est Madame la covid madame la
covid m'a sauvé pourquoi elle m'a sauvé
parce qu'elle a arrêté le sport pendant
la covid toutes les manifestations
sportives ont été arrêté donc si tu veux
j'ai pas souffert parce qu'il avaient
pas lieu les les les toi que tu voyais
une manifestation sportive qui se
passait sans toi ça devait être voilà
sauf que la covid m'a pris sous sa
protection et m'a dit stop il y aura pas
de manifestation sportive et donc si tu
veux ça m'a permis de me rebecter un peu
et puis après et ben après j'ai eu je
suis tombé sur un truc incroyable je
suis allé à la Réunion faire la
Diagonale des Fous qui est un trail de
100 je sais plus combien 80 km et là
j'ai rencontré des gens qui étaient des
sport de très haut niveau qu'on
connaissait pas c'était monsieur et
madame tout le monde c'était des gens
qui étaient passionnés comme moi et
quand tu as 100 ou 12 km dans les pattes
avec un dénivelé de plus 10000 et cetera
et ben tu tu te tu te vides et tu
racontes des histoires tu racontes et
c'est ces histoires là aujourd'hui que
je que je relais tes proches ils te
disaient quoi quand tu rentres tu
rentres mes proches heureusement qu'ils
étaient là je et ben heureusement qu'ils
était là je peux dire que ma femme
heureusement qu'elle était là elle
bossait à france télé avant donc ouais
donc en plus elle a tu connais son
docteur oui connais bien ouais ça
commence par ange ça se termine par
Anouna non mais c'est vrai sais qu'
c'est pour ça qu'elle est en bonne santé
et je peux te dire que grâce à elle j'ai
j'ai tenu le choc ouais ouais vraiment
bah oui parce que ouais parce que enfin
tu tu sais ce que c'est si on pr
d'antenne toi tu vas qu'est-ce que tu
vas faire tu vis tu vis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Ken mais tu as pas hte de dire ça rigole
mon Patrick je rigole ça va vous
applaudissez tous
oui oui Patrick est-ce que vous êtes sûr
que c'est pour ça vraiment ben pourquoi
vous êes vous avez été il pense que
c'est pour l'âge Patrick non mais est-ce
que parce que vous savez le service des
sports à un moment donné il a été
complètement nettoyer oui non ça rien à
voir vous pensez que ça n rien à voir
renir rien à voir ok non non c'est deux
choses concomitantes mais complètement
non non rien à voir donc rien à voir
avec les affaires de sexi non non non
rien à voir Alex oui moi j'ai une
question Patrick par que moi j'ai eu la
chance de commenter des matchs avec Ti
Roland j'ai déjeuné avec sa femme il y a
pas longtempsta heure non mais je
raconte fa raconter l'histoire de
Patrick pour dire ce ce qu'il pense je
comprends pas pourquoi aujourd'hui vous
avez un média on donne des accredes au
JO pour n'importe qui vous avez radio
Montel est-ce que vous avez essayé de
demander avec 270000 personnes qui vous
écoutent demander la CR au J pour
pouvoir faire ce que vous ré j'ai c'est
la c'est la la la question qui me touche
au plus profond j'ai fait tout ce qu'il
fallait pour avoir l'accréditation je me
suis adressé au cnoosf Comité national
olympique et sportif français qui
distribue les
acredes et j'ai eu un refus et je ne
comprends pas parce que j'ai le droit de
commenter les championnats du monde pour
Radio Montel je suis accrédité les
championnats d'Europe j'ai le droit les
jeux olympiqu chez moi j'ai pas le droit
et je sais pas pourquoi et je crois que
ça emmerde quelqu'un est-ce que tu crois
pas que France Télé joue un rôle
làdedans je sais pas Jacques
ce diffuseur France diff frl responsable
d'une certaine façon c'est pas France
tél qui F les ACC non enfin il les
demande il les demand je peux pas croire
ça je peux pas croire ça je sais que ça
emmerde quelqu'un je je sais pas qui
c'est mais il y a quelqu'un qui bloque
et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui cette
pétition que j'ai que j'ai pas du tout
initié aujourd'hui elle me permet de
m'exprimer et je dis ouvertement à la
personne qui
bloque pitié pitié débloquer ça je vais
pas prendre de place je prends la place
de personne je serai dans un petit coin
je ferais chier personneend tu parles
quand même Patrick tu disais euh il y a
peut-être la question de l'âge les
questions du dopage ça a été un prétexte
concernant bien s est-ce que tu crois
pas tu as été victime du fameux syndrome
du mal de plus de 50 ans et blanc écoute
je veux pas rentrer là-dedans Jacques tu
sais très bien moi je vais vois très
bien où tu vas revenir tua tu avais pas
70 ans tu pouvais rester ouais mais bon
j'avais j'étais pas loin de 70 non je
veux pas rentrer là-dedans je veux pas
rentrer
là-dedans écoute je sais pas j'ai
aujourd'hui j'ai fait la paix avec ça
j'ai pas envie de franchement raayon
qu'est-ce que tu en penses moi je vais
te dire ce que j'en pense Patrick et en
toute honnête je pense que d'abord il y
a y a Thierry Gilardi et a toi pour moi
vous êtes êtes que deux dans le
commentaire il y a il y a toi il y a dir
néanmoins ce métier rend dingue ce
métier rend fou et ce métier vous enlève
complètement tout le recul parce que des
gens qui sont fait virer d'une boîte au
bout de 25 30 ans 35 ans avec rien il y
en a plein il y en a plein il y en a
plein toi tu as négocié ton départ
maintenant je t'encourage à faire ton
médiia parce que tu vas gêner tu as déjà
270000 tu vas gêner mais né en moins ce
métier rend complètement malade il rend
fou est-ce que tu peux comprendrevie com
je exactement com on a T de s' priv de
s' Pr l'accréditation franchement il
pourrait avoir l'accréditation non mais
patri vous gênez vous savez très bien
vous n'avez pas l'accréditation parce
que vous gênez alors France Télévision
et le le la présidence des GO 2024 à
Paris comme ils sont diffuseurs ils sont
très proches il manque plus que certains
athlètes disent on lui a pas pardonné et
vous êtes le Bou émissaire de vous-même
donc en fait on ne veut pas de vous pour
tout ce que vous êtes c'est ça qui est
dégueulasse moi je dis on ne on ne peut
pas se priver de Monteil pour les Jeux
Olympiques c'est la voix de l'athlétisme
mais il y a trop de gens qui vous en
volent et là maintenant vous êtes
victime estce vous êtes d'accord avec
Patrick juste oui il est d'accord avec
ça bien sûr qu'il est d'accord Patrick
juste si tu fais pas les les Joos tu vas
pas les regarder regarder ou pas les non
je vais te dire ce que je vais faire si
je vais pas les Joos c'est en fait je
ferai les gios parce que même si j'ai
pas d'acraide tu vois je vais aller dans
un commissariat de police je vais aller
dans un épad je vais aller dans une
crèche je vais aller je sais pas où et
je vais commenter dans une crèche tu vas
réveiller les enfants mais pas aussi oui
ça oui c'est vraiou tu peux le proposer
à des collectivités non mais mais
form ben c'est ce que je vais faire
c'est ce que je vais faire patri ça te
stresse là les Jeux Olympiques qui
arrivent et tu dis il faut que j'y sois
absolument contre la mononde pour toi
mais tu est-ce que tu te rends compte
que les derniers jeux ils ont lieu en
1924 que des que mes maîtres Thierry
Rolland Roger couder Robert Chapat n'ont
jamais vécu les Jeux Olympiques en
France ce sont des des des éverestes
pour moi et moi petit machin je peux le
faire je peux le faire je demande juste
juste un bout de carton avec mon nom
marqué dessus je prends la place de
personne je me met le fais là tuux je te
le fais là si tu mais tu sais que tu as
ce pouvoir en plus tu le sais ça attends
parce que tu as tu as tu as un réseau
que moi j'ai pas Cyril alors oui non je
je suis ass
faire l'art du rebond non non non mais
Patrick est-ce que tu en J à France
Télévision non comment tuen veux pas
France pas du tout Patrick en tout cas
moi je vais te dire un truc ce soir je
vais tout faire ah attention je te le
dis je vais tout faire pour que tu sois
quelque part pour les Jos sur une
antenne ça serait magnifique tu peux pas
savoir et là tu peux pas savoir j'ai pas
je vais essayer faire le max je te dis
pas que tu vais réussir mais je vais
faire le maximum si tu si tu quand je te
dis le max c'est le max si tu arrives à
faire ça honnêtement et je précise un
truc je ne veux pas être payé jeux faire
ça